[MUSIC PLAYING]
TYLER BUI-PALSULICH: My
name is Tyler Bui-Palsulich.
I'm a developer program's
engineer at Google,
and I work on Go and
Google Cloud Platform.
My goal is essentially to
make it as enjoyable and easy
to use Go with and on
Google Cloud as possible.
So with that said,
I'm going to be
talking about running
and maintaining
Go's serverless applications.
And I specifically put running
and maintaining in the title
here because getting
something running
and started is only
part of the process.
You make it available
once, you need
to keep it available and fast
and usable for your users.
So with that said, I
think kind of the best way
to do this is with a demo.
So what I'm going
to be doing today
is building a web application.
It's very, very complicated.
You may have heard
of it before, maybe.
Let me know.
It's called Hello World.
All right.
Couple of people.
And I'm going to be
starting from scratch today,
and I'm using Cloud Shell here.
So Cloud Shell is a
service from Google Cloud
where we spin up
a virtual machine,
and then give you a terminal.
So if you go to console.cloud.go
ogle.com/cloudshell,
you come here.
As long as you have an
account, you get to this page,
so anything I'm showing today
you can hopefully do yourself.
And the first step will
be setting a project.
So config set project.
And I created one for this
talk called serverless gopher
because that's what we all are.
And I'm going to create
a new directory called
hello [INAUDIBLE] into that.
I really did create it.
It didn't exist before--
nothing in here.
And the first step
in any Go project
is creating a new Go module.
So how many people have
heard of modules before?
Awesome.
Tons of people.
All right.
So to create a module, you're
going to use go mod init
example.com/--
I'm going to call this hello.
And this creates one file
called go.mod in this directory.
And right now-- this
is really simple--
it has two main lines.
One is module example.com/hello.
This gives us the
name of this module.
All of the Go packages that we
create inside of this module
will be prefixed by
this module name.
And then the other
line says go 1.12.
So you can see here
I'm using go 1.12.
It's the default
for Cloud Shell.
And what this 1.12 line in
the module file is saying
is this module was
built with 1.12.
That's the intention.
So if you're on something
older, say 1.11,
optimistically try
to compile with this.
If it works, awesome.
If it doesn't, well,
because you need 1.12.
So it's kind of this forward
looking idea of hopefully,
in the future, as we
add more things to Go,
we can support modules
back and forth.
With that said, let's
actually write some Go code.
So I'm going to start by
creating a web handler,
and I'm just going to do this
with the standard library
net HTTP package.
Package hello.
We're going to have one
function called hello,
and it will always respond
with, Hello, World.
And this is following
the handler func.
That's our goal for this.
So we need two arguments
for this function.
One is a response writer
from the HTTP package,
and the other is a request.
No return arguments.
And then for every
request, we're
just going to
respond with Fprintf
respond with Hello, World.
And that's it.
And straight off the bat here--
save.
Get imports.
Cool.
Straight off the bat here,
this is an HTTP Cloud Function
in Go.
Cloud Functions for Go are
just HTTP handler funcs.
From the standard library,
all of the usual middleware,
if you have logging to say dump
debug information about all
of your requests
or your responses
should just work out of the box.
So let's take a look at
actually deploying this.
So, to do that-- all clear--
we're going to use the G
Cloud command line tool.
So G Cloud Functions deploy.
And I'm going to give the
name of the Cloud Function
that I want to deploy, and you
can also specify an entry point
argument.
The default for this argument is
the name of the Cloud Function
that you are deploying.
In this case, I can
just leave it off,
and then it defaults
to Hello, which
is the function we just wrote.
And then we need
two other arguments.
One is the runtime.
So I'm going to use go111.
And for Cloud
Functions, go111 just
went generally available
at Next a couple days ago,
and then 1.12 is
available in Alpha.
So if you're interested in
that, find me after the show,
and I can get you signed up.
The other argument we need
is what trigger type do we
need for this Cloud Function?
And in this case, I'm
going to use HTTP.
And HTTP means this code
is going to be deployed.
We're copying up--
or the G Cloud tool
will copy up all of the
current directory, which
means our current module, send
that up to Google servers.
It will build that code,
make sure it's working,
and then make that endpoint
URL available, ideally.
And so in this case,
I'm using HTTP,
but there's one other
type of Cloud Function
that you can write.
Those are background functions.
And background functions
respond to events that happen.
And in a way, you can
think of visiting some HTTP
URL as an event that happens,
but what I mean in this case is
something like Pub/Sub.
So Pub/Sub is this
distributed message bus
where you can send messages into
it on a topic that you define,
and then subscribe
to it other places.
And if you're running on, say,
Compute Engine or App Engine
or somewhere else, you
might subscribe manually
to that topic.
With Cloud Functions, you
don't have to do that.
You just say, attach this Cloud
Function to this Pub/Sub topic.
Every message that
gets published here,
trigger this Cloud Function.
So that's really nice.
In this case, we have
an HTTPS function.
You can visit it, click that
link, and you get Hello, World.
Awesome.
And so you can also do
things like Cloud storage
where, let's say, a user
uploads a profile picture
and you need to
process that picture
to, say, make a
thumbnail that you can
display on your application.
That's the perfect use
case for Cloud Functions
because you send that into
a Cloud Storage bucket,
your function gets
triggered, processed,
do whatever image
manipulation you need to do,
and start somewhere else.
But that doesn't always
make the most sense
for your entire application.
You might have something that's,
say, directly user facing.
Maybe it has multiple endpoints
that are all working together
and the user travels
between them.
In that case, it
might make more sense
to use something
like App Engine.
And with App Engine, you
get an entire HTTP binary
that you can be running.
So again, let's kind of take a
look at what that looks like.
So we have our go.mod
file, our hello.go file,
and we're going to create one
more directory called cmd.
And in cmd, we are going
to create a main package--
main.go.
And this is a really
common pattern
in writing Go applications where
you create whatever top level
libraries and packages that
you might need to use and then
have a subdirectory for each
binary that you would have.
So you might have a back end
binary, a front end binary,
and so on.
And those would be in command
back end, command front end,
and so on.
In this case, I'm just going
to write one web server,
so I'm doing just in
the command directory.
So in here we have package main.
Going to write a func main.
And this has a few steps.
One-- we're going to check what
port should we be listening on.
So the App Engine runtime
will set the port environment
variable to the port that
you should be listening on
for your HTTP server.
Other than that, whatever
setup you need to do
can all be dependent
on your application
however you prefer to write it.
But it is helpful to have
a default port in case
that environment
variable is not set.
So for this, I'll do 8080.
And then we need to
register our handler,
so we'll do http.HandleFunc.
Listen on our port.
Use the default-- or the
handler that we just wrote,
which is in the hello package
and it was named hello.
If everything is working
with modules and Go imports,
when I save this
file, it should just
show up as one of the imports.
That's what I was saying before.
All of the packages
that we create
are just prefixed
by that module path.
We'll see that in a sec.
Let's log a message that says
where we're listening to.
So listening on local host, and
then some port to a new line.
And finally, we can
start our server.
And I'm wrapping this
in a log.Fatal call
so that, when our server ends,
if there is some error that
triggered the end
of that server,
we should print
that to the console
and not just forget about it.
So we do that with
http.ListenAndServe.
So we need our port--
oops-- up here.
We don't want to
lesson on a port.
We want to lesson on
some end point, which is,
we'll say /hello.
Here we're listening on
some port, default marks,
close fatal, and there we go.
So at the top here, we have a
few imports from the standard
library, and we have
this example.com/hello.
And that's really it.
And this is how you
would write an HTTP
server with a standard library.
Maybe you have some extra
routing logic and things
like that, but this is just how
you write HTTP servers in Go.
And in my opinion,
it's super convenient
because this is an
App Engine server.
You can deploy this
almost directly.
Before we do that--
it's helpful before you
try to deploy something
on a Cloud service, you
might want to run it locally.
And in this case, if it's
a Hello World web server,
how can we do that?
Well, call go build.
Let's output this to
the current directory
as a binary named hello, and
the binaries in the command sub
directory.
So that's going to
build a hello binary.
So we get this log message,
listening on local host 8080.
And I know what you're thinking.
You're like, Tyler, you're
in Cloud Shell right now.
That's in some data
center probably
in Kansas or something.
Where's local host?
So there's a convenient--
I found out about this
as I was prepping this,
but there's this
web preview up here,
and you can specify a port.
And then you get
some endpoint here.
And this is pretending
like local host
for you proxied
through Cloud Shell.
And if yet it's HTTPS up here,
the authentication is required.
So if you open an incognito
window, it says Sign In.
So only you as the developer--
it's just secure by default--
can access this.
Really nice.
Helpful for prototyping.
If you're on a
Chromebook or working
in Cloud Shell in general--
really helpful.
All right.
So we can close those,
stop our server.
And to deploy an App Engine,
we need one more file
called an app.yml.
And we're going to do
App Engine standard here.
I'll talk about
flexible in a second.
But we need a couple lines.
One is the runtime.
Again, we're going to use go111.
For App Engine, there's go111,
and go112 just went to beta.
So if you want to
use that, you can.
In this case, I'll
stick with 111 SGA.
And then we need
another line that
says what is the main package?
What is the binary that we
are going to be running?
In that case, or
in this case, it's
in the command sub directory.
And this is helpful for modules
because as you're developing
your application,
your binary might
be a few directories
deep, and that's
super common and super
helpful and a nice way
to design your application.
But for App Engine, you need
to deploy that entire module
so you can import
everything that's needed.
We have our binary
importing hello, so we need
this entire module directory.
So we say the main command
is cmd, save, and then
we can run G Cloud app.
Deploy.
And this is going to go through
the same kind of build process
that we went through for
Cloud Functions where
the current code gets zipped
up, sent to Cloud Storage--
you can see uploading three
files to Cloud Storage--
it builds on Google
servers, makes
sure that the application
works, and then
deploys it at your end point.
So you might have
some custom domain,
or you can see
this is going to go
at
serverless-gopher.appspot.com.
So this is using App Engine
standard and, specifically,
App Engine standard second
gen, or second generation.
And that's built on top of
gVisor, which gives Sandbox
security to your application.
So that means any package
that you want to use, you can.
In first generation run
times on App Engine,
you had to use specific
packages to do things
like HTTP requests.
So you would go to use
just standard HTTP default
client get, and then you
would get some runtime failure
when you deployed
your application
saying you can't do that.
Same thing with contexts.
Now you can use whatever
context you want.
You can just grab the
request context directly,
and you don't have
to worry about it.
App Engine flexible is
similar to App Engine standard
except you get to--
one, it has a minimum
instance count of one.
So with standard, you
can go down to zero.
Flex, you have to
have a minimum of one.
That means you're being
charged as it runs.
If no one's using it, you're
still paying money for it.
Not very nice to use.
A nice thing is that you
get container images,
but I'll talk about container
images after I show you this.
So let's take this URL.
We just deployed it.
Copy.
We defined the /hello end
point, and we get Hello, World.
Awesome.
I'll call out here, we
didn't make any changes
to the Cloud Function
that we deployed,
and that's kind of the point.
The code that you're
writing shouldn't
be dependent on where
you're deploying it.
Kind of the Go code in one
place is the Go code in another.
But sometimes you
need one more level
of granularity, higher than,
say, App Engine, or just
the binary.
And so that might be because
you need additional tools that
are right next to your server
that your server might,
say, shell out to.
Or you define some
native code that
depends on the type of
machine that's running it.
And in those cases, you
can use a container.
And containers can be
deployed in a serverless way--
same kind of scaling up
and down as you need--
with Cloud Run.
So Cloud Run, announced,
again, a couple of days
ago, does serverless containers.
So you say, I'm going to
deploy this container,
or I'm pushing it and I'm
storing it on Google Container
Registry, and then deploy
that and it scales as needed.
So let's take a look at
what that looks like.
We're going to need to
define our container
in some way, and a super
common way to do that--
most common-- is
with a Docker file.
So I have one already written.
Ignore the fact that says buggy.
I'll get to that in a sec.
And let's take a look
at this Docker file.
So we start on line one here and
we say from golang as builder,
this is the kind of root image
that we're going to be building
our container image in, say,
work in the /home directory.
And I'll call out for Go
applications, this line
five and six is really nice.
This says copy in the
go.mod and go.sum files
and then run go.mod download.
And that's helpful
because these are
run in different Docker stages,
and they get cached as needed.
So if your go.mod and your
go.sum files don't change,
then you don't have to
rerun go.mod download.
That's really nice when you're
developing because you aren't
changing your dependencies
every time you save and test
or deploy, so you
shouldn't have to download
all of those dependencies
every single time
you try to build your container.
So that means it might take a
couple minutes the first time
because you have to
download everything, right,
and then you make some
modification to your code,
and then it's just basically
the compile time plus whatever
it takes for Docker to start.
Really nice.
I recommend it.
Regardless of where you're
building and running your code,
do this if you're
running some container.
Line seven says copy
the rest of it in.
We compile our binary.
And then this is
done as a multi-stage
build where the second
stage is done from Alpine.
And Alpine is a trimmed
down, smaller base image
that doesn't have extra things
that aren't really needed
to run a static binary,
which you get with Go.
But one thing we do
need is certificates.
And certificates are
useful for, basically,
if you're doing anything
with SSL or HTTPS,
you'll want to
include this line.
Finally, we copy our binary.
Make sure it's executable.
Set that port
environment variable
that I defined or
talked about earlier.
And then the command
to start it is /hello.
So I deployed this already
on Google Container Registry,
and you can see that at
gcr.io/serverless-gopher.
And this is the
project that I created.
And you can see I have
one image in here.
It's called helloworld.
And there are two
versions of this.
One is 1.0.0, and the
other is 1.0.0-buggy.
So like I said, I'll get
back to buggy in a second,
but for right now, I'm going
to apply the 1.0 version.
And to do that, we are
going to use G Cloud again.
So G Cloud beta.
Run.
Deploy.
And then the one argument
we need is image.
And this is going to be
exactly what that image I just
showed you was.
So gcr.io/serverless
gopher/helloworld and then you
can also specify your version.
The default version is latest.
In this case, I'm
going to do 1.0.0
which we just talked about.
So we hit Deploy here,
and this time, we
aren't copying the source
from the current directory.
It's just going to download
that image from the container
registry.
I'm going specify US central.
Service name-- it defaults
to the image name,
and we get this deploying
container image.
We get one option here--
allow unauthenticated
invocations to service.
Yes.
That basically means we don't
need to log in to hit this,
and it's just a little
bit more convenient,
at least for this demo.
And so here, it creates a new
service, pulls down that image,
starts it up, performs
a health check,
reroutes traffic to your
new version as needed,
and as you can see, it
literally took a few seconds.
Let's open this URL just
to make sure it works.
We're at /hello and
we get Hello, World.
Very cool.
And so kind of from so far--
we started with HTTP functions.
You might have many of
these for your application.
They might do many
different things.
You might have some
background functions
that are part of your app.
But either way, you start
with these HTTP handlers.
Maybe you say, I need a
little bit more control.
I want to bundle all
of this up together.
I want to not have these
independently scalable small,
stateless bits of code
called Cloud Functions.
I'm going to deploy this
as a single binary HTTP
server that's running.
And then if that's not
quite enough, or you need,
like I said those native
binaries, or those extra tools
right next to it, you might add
a container image around that
and deploy that on Cloud Run.
So, for Go specific, I've
found it really helpful
to have these containers
to build a Go funct
as a service with a co-worker.
So that you could just
bundle in those Go tools
that you needed
in your container.
When you're running on App
Engine, is Go installed?
I don't know.
If you run on a
container, I do know
because you say in that
Docker file, yes, I need Go,
or I need ImageMagick.
ImageMagick is included in App
Engine, but you get the point.
So that's where I've
really liked using it.
But kind of looking at the
big picture here, running it
isn't the end of the story.
The point of
running something is
to do something awesome with it.
And you might have all
of these other things
around it, like you're
using ML, Cloud Vision,
or building some
chat bot, and so on.
And the point is not just
to have that code running
on App Engine.
It's to do something
cool with it.
And regardless, you kind of
have to maintain that and keep
it going.
So now that we have
something running,
let's talk and shift gears into
talking about maintaining it
and keeping it going.
In the first line of defense
that I really see is testing.
So it's not really a fun topic.
It's kind of a boring
topic maybe sometimes,
but what I want to
call out here is
that testing for deploying on
GCF or App Engine or Cloud Run
is just testing.
You aren't running
something special that
says because I am running
on Cloud Functions,
I need this extra stuff.
It should just be
a normal Go test.
If you've ever written
Go code, if you've
written Go test before,
this is what they look like.
In this case, this is
using the HTTP test
package from the
standard library
and checks the response
code as data's OK.
If you do have kind of multiple
things going on and you want
to test that altogether--
you have production--
I recommend creating
test projects as needed.
And your test project can
be completely independent
of all of your
production resources,
and then you don't
have to have worry
about running out or
accidentally deleting something
from production if it's just
a completely separate Google
Cloud project.
The other thing to keep
in mind-- and this is
kind of true for any
microservice application
that you're building--
is implicit dependencies.
So I built one
application where users
could go to a
website and request
translations of certain text.
So you get free form input
for what text, and then
a selector box for what
language should that text
be translated to.
And so that request--
that form post response--
gets sent to some server.
And then I didn't want
to run that translation
right there, right
then because it
might take a little bit longer.
It might take 100 milliseconds.
It might take more.
So what I did was I published
all of those to Pub/Sub,
and I said here on this
topic, go translate this text
into French.
And then I created
a Cloud Function
that listened on that Pub/Sub
topic, brought things in,
said OK, I'm going to take
that text, translate to French,
store it in the database,
and then the user refreshes
and they get the
list of translations
from that database.
That's awesome.
But you kind of have this
implicit dependency there.
You have one code that's
pushing into Pub/Sub
and this other code that's
pulling down from Pub/Sub,
and they have that implicit
dependency that says,
what is the format of that data
that's going back and forth?
If you're calling it
directly, you're writing Go,
it just type checks,
it compiles--
you're good.
But if you're going
through Pub/Sub,
if you're publishing
events and so on,
you have to be a
lot more careful.
So I don't have a hard
and fast rule that says,
what's the best
way to manage this?
But documenting it, having
a good clear picture
of where all of the data of
your application is going,
will be super helpful.
And the other issue
is visibility.
So it's like, yeah,
sure, Tyler, you're
running all these containers
that go up and down.
You have, whatever,
25 containers here.
What's inside these containers?
30.
It's OK.
What's inside these containers?
Anyone?
I don't know.
So you need that extra
visibility to say,
what's inside these?
How are they communicating
back and forth?
Is it fast?
Can I debug it?
And the way to do that, or at
least one way, is with tracing.
So tracing-- there's a package
or a library called OpenCensus,
and this is instrumented
in multiple languages--
in this case, I'm show Go--
but the same principles apply.
You start by creating
spans and then
you end those spans at
some point in the future.
In this case, I'm
creating a span called
example.com/hello.hello.
And the convention for creating
these is you take your package
name dot the function name.
That way, later, if you
ever need to debug and find
the code that's
creating this span,
you know exactly where to go.
And then this call
is defer span.end.
And defer means
this end call will
run when the function returns,
or at the end of the function.
And then what you get from
this is it returns a context,
and as you pass
that context around
through your
application, you get
to see these other
spans that are created.
And as you create a new
span from this context,
it all gets attributed to the
parent, or top level span,
that created this.
So we'll see an
example of what this
looks like in a little bit.
Once you do that, you have to
export that data somewhere.
So like I said, OpenCensus is
open source multiple languages.
One benefit of that is
that the exporter can
be whatever you want it to be.
So that might be
Stackdriver, which
I have an example of here.
Stackdriver is Google Cloud's
application performance
monitoring suite.
But it might be
Datadog, or it might
be some local just print it to
standard out as I'm developing.
And that makes it
really easy to recommend
tracing throughout
your entire code
because if you
ever want to change
where you're exporting that
data later, it doesn't matter.
It's a small, maybe 10
line, configuration change
that says export
this somewhere else.
The other side of
kind of the same coin
is tracing you have
to explicitly add--
or maybe there are
plugins to help you.
For example, there is a
OpenCensus HTTP plugin.
So you just say trace
all of these handlers,
and it just works.
The other side of that
coin, without having
to do much manual
work, is profiling.
And profiling
gives you, say, CPU
or heap usage of your code
by calling this start call.
So what's this look like?
Again, let's do a demo.
You may have guessed
already, but let's
deploy that buggy version
that I talked about earlier.
So we look here.
We have 1.0 and 1.0.0-buggy.
Let's deploy this on Cloud Run.
And, for this version,
I made a few changes.
One or two of them
are I added tracing
and I added profiling,
which I just talked about,
and then I also
added two other bugs.
So my hope is that I can deploy
this, throw some traffic at it
just to make sure those
bugs get triggered,
and then we can go
look at the tracing
and profiling tools
in the Cloud console
to hopefully find those bugs.
So we'll stick with us-central1.
Same service name.
This will deploy.
It should take just a
couple of seconds here.
Doing the same thing.
Assigning traffic to
the latest revision.
And done.
I'll use curl just to make
sure this is still working.
Oops.
/hello.
Go delete all of
this extra stuff.
Cool.
We're still getting
Hello, World.
Everything is still working.
No obvious bugs, at least
from this perspective.
That one took a
little bit longer.
So one option-- we could send
a few thousand curl requests
and we could go home
sometime around dinner.
Or there's another
tool called hey.
And what hey can do
is we can take this--
clear hey-- and -z is going
to be how long we run for.
All right.
And hey was bought by a
coworker of mine, JBD,
and it's written
in Go, and it can
send a configurable amount
of traffic at the URL
that you specify.
So in this case, we're going
to say run for two minutes,
send a bunch of requests
to this end point.
While that's going, over
here, let's open trace.
And I'll call out, on
this overview page,
there are reports of the
different traces that you get.
So you might get a distribution
of how long that trace took.
You can see latency and
request percentiles,
and then example traces that
correspond to those requests.
In this case, let's just
look at real time responses
that are coming in.
And I'll restrict this to
example.com/hello.hello which
was the span that we care about.
Zoom in on recent code.
And immediately
calling out here,
we have a bunch of
requests at the bottom.
Those look fine.
Those look like about zero.
Great.
We have another line at
about 300 milliseconds.
That's probably not what we're
looking for a hello world
application.
So that's something
to look into.
And then the third
group is we have
all of these clustered kind of
in the middle, random latency
traces.
And so just to say the x-axis
on this is the timeline.
And so as you go more left,
you get older and older.
And then the y-axis is how
long it took in milliseconds.
And so when we click one
of these dots down here,
we get this timeline
at the bottom, which
includes all of our spans.
So this request took
zero milliseconds.
I would say that's an
acceptable amount of time.
All of these are taking zero.
And then you can
see we have this one
span of the hello span.
And let's look up here
at 300 milliseconds.
So we have our hello
span, and then inside
of that there is a slow span.
And this is eating up that
entire 300 milliseconds.
So looking at the name of this,
we have example.com/hello.slow.
It's pretty clear
where we can look--
when we take a look at the
source code that I deployed
in a little bit--
where we can look and
hopefully find out why this
is taking 300 milliseconds.
All of these other
ones in here--
96 milliseconds-- 95.
Why?
You look here, you have spans.
Nothing is there.
Nothing is really helpful.
Nothing's showing up.
But it's still taking
95 milliseconds.
What is there to do about that?
So astute gopher, as
you can probably guess,
we have profiling.
And profiling-- the
default here is CPU time.
You also want to double check--
so you have hello
world and hello world
test as your services--
check that you're
using the right service
or looking at the
right service here.
I've spent more time
than I care to admit
looking at the wrong
one and wondering
why profiling wasn't there.
Just take it from my experience.
You can specify what version
you want to look for.
Let's say what time frame
you want to look at.
And immediately jumping
out here is Fibonacci.
And you can probably
guess what this is doing,
but before I get there, this
is called a flame graph.
And a flame graph is
giving you some metric--
in this case, it's CPU
time, but like I said,
it could also be say
a heap allocation--
where on the x-axis, you
have how much of that metric
did this function call
take across the profiles
that we've received?
On the y-axis, you
have the stack depth
of the functions
that were called.
So if we start at the top here,
we have some standard library
things at connection.serve,
serve handler, serve HTTP,
and so on, until
we get to hello,
which was the handler
that we wrote.
And then right underneath
this, we're calling Fibonacci.
And Fibonacci is a very
wide, very deep stack thing,
and we'll see what the code
is for this in a second.
Not every time you
look at profiling
it's going to be this
obvious, but it's just
another tool in the box to check
of where is the CPU time going?
Why is this request
taking 100 milliseconds?
Look at profiling-- very clear.
So let's take a look at
what that looks like.
So let's do cd into buggy.
This is all the same
code that I wrote before.
There's no app.yml here
because since we're just
deploying a container image
and not on App Engine,
we don't need that app.yml so
you won't see it right here.
All of the other code is the
same except for the changes
that I made.
So let's take a look
at what that looks for.
We will delete that.
Not worried about swap.
All right.
You can see we have extra
imports here of opencensus.io.
And then there is the
Stackdriver exporter variable
on line 15.
And then in an init
function, which
is run during package
initialization for your Go
program.
I create a new
Stackdriver exporter,
just like I showed you.
Register that as
the trace exporter.
And then line 24 here,
I want to call this out.
As you're developing
your application,
you're adding tracing,
you say, yeah,
export my data to Stackdriver.
You do it.
Nothing shows up.
That's because,
by default, there
is sampling that goes
into all of the traces.
You don't necessarily
need to sample
or send traces for every
single request that comes in.
So you can sample, say,
1% or 0.5%, or 0.1%,
depending on the level
of traffic that you need
and the visibility into all
of the requests that you have.
When you're debugging, you
want maximum visibility.
You're not concerned about QPS.
Just show me the traces.
Are they working?
In that case, you need
this line right here
that says always sample.
Always send that data.
Don't do any 1%
magic or anything.
There are a bunch of options
that you can look into,
but I want to call that one out.
Finally, you can
see in our handler
we have this hello
span that we created.
Like I said before,
OpenCensus has HTTP plugins
that will give you
even more information
and help you debug
your web applications.
So I wouldn't do it this
way if you're writing it.
Look into that OCHTTP package.
And then you get to
the bugs that I added.
So it's a switch that creates
a random number that's
either zero, one, or two.
If it's a zero, we're going
to call this slow function.
If it's a one, we
call Fibonacci.
So we'll start by
looking at slow,
and you can see we have
a span that we created--
hello.slow right
here-- and then we
call time.sleep for
300 milliseconds.
Probably not something you
want to do in your production
application, but it's
immediately obvious
where to look and
how to fix this.
Maybe, I don't know, we want
to sleep for 100 milliseconds,
or just none.
And then we have Fibonacci.
And Fibonacci returns
the Fibonacci number,
and it does nothing special.
It's just recursive,
has no caching,
and it's immediately obvious--
yes, this is something
that we could focus on.
We can spend our developer
time and engineering effort
optimizing this function.
And yeah.
So with that, we started
with this Cloud Function.
We added in a main.go,
a package main
to call that function,
deployed that on App Engine,
added a Docker file to
create our container image,
and then deployed
that on Cloud Run.
Then I showed you a few tips of
adding tracing and profiling.
And so tracing is a little bit
higher effort than profiling.
Profiling-- you have a few lines
of code that say, enable this.
Tracing-- you have
to plumb context
throughout your
entire application.
And how many people have done
that, or at least tried to,
where you look at context
and you're like, OK,
I need to pass this through
my entire application how?
And I'm going to update how?
So that's kind of
a slow process.
And, if you have a
very big application
with a large team of
engineers working on it,
one team might not have that
as their priority for a quarter
when another does.
So it's helpful to
have those kind of two
parts of the same
side, or the same coin,
to get different visibility.
Testing-- like I said,
tests should just be tests.
Your Go code should just
be Go code, hopefully
with the caveat of you
have some authentication
requirements, depending
on where you're deploying
and things like that.
But the code that you're writing
should always look like Go code
without extra
surprises, just based
on where you're deploying it.
And, with that said, that's
all I have for today.
Your feedback would be
greatly appreciated.
You can do that in the app.
And if you have
any questions, you
can either find me on Twitter,
or I'll be out in the hall
after the talk.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]